verblüffende fakten zur pubertät jeder
von uns hat sie durchgemacht und mehr
oder weniger gelitten heute im special
von klicks um science-fiction dreht sich
alles um diesen zeitraum 5 verblüffende
fakten zur pubertät jetzt 140 jahren
legte man den start der pubertät ganze
vier jahre später an die kicks die
kinder und jugendgesundheit untersuchung
berichtet dass derzeit mädchen schon im
alter von zwölf acht jahren im schnitt
also ungefähr im dreizehnten lebensjahr
ihre erste periode haben die zahl 12 8
nähert sich dabei wohl immer mehr der
zahl elf immer häufiger bekommen mädchen
schon mit elf jahren ihre erste
menstruation früher waren die mädchen
bei ihrer ersten regelblutung also
zwischen so 16 17 18 jahre alt heute
bringen mädchen in diesem alter zum teil
schon leider die ersten kinder zur welt
forscher rätseln noch immer über die
ursachen der pubertät verschiebung
bessere lebensbedingungen könnten darauf
einfluss genommen haben besonders stark
habe die bessere lebensmittelversorgung
dazu beigetragen vermuten die forscher
neben den 140 jahren in denen sich die
pubertät verschoben hat gibt es auch
eine krankheit die eine weitere
verschiebung zum leidwesen der
betroffenen verursacht hubertus praecox
ist eine krankheit die die pubertät um
einige jahre nach vorne verlegt
entstehen kann eine solche erkrankung
durch einen erhöhten druck auf den
hypothalamus im gehirn
der hypothalamus verantwortet die
hormonausschüttung wenn ein tumor darauf
drückt wird diese produktion enorm in
die höhe getrieben 80 prozent der
betroffenen sind weiblich schon im
frühen kindesalter entwickeln sich bei
den mädchen die brust ansätze und das
körperwachstum beträgt teilweise über 8
cm pro jahr
diese störung der hormonausschüttung
muss behandelt werden andernfalls können
drastische psychische und physische
fehlentwicklungen die folge sein
mit einer hormonbehandlung kann den
betroffenen vom probert das black ops
mais geholfen werden
wenn jungs sind die pubertät kommen
pöbeln sie nur noch rum und machen einen
auf möchtegern rambos okay das mag
manchmal noch zu treffen
forscher der universität in potsdam
sehen die schuld dafür aber nicht bei
den jungs selbst mädchen würden den
impuls dazu geben innerhalb von drei
jahren beobachtete der sozialpsychologe
oberbuch 1321 schüler in berlin zweimal
im jahr bekamen die schüler eine kleine
inszenierte geschichte zu lesen inhalt
der geschichte sich gegenseitig
provozierende jugendliche die schüler
sollten sich in die protagonisten
hineinversetzen und entscheiden was sie
tun würden
zuschlagen oder das gespräch suchen
parallel zu der aufgabe wurden die
probanden zu mobbing und so weiter
befragt wenn sie das letzte mal mal
jemanden geärgert hatten und so weiter
umso friedlicher die klassengemeinschaft
war umso friedlicher fielen auch die
antworten aus besonders starken einfluss
auf das ergebnis hatten dabei die
mädchen warum jungs wollen ihre
gleichaltrigen kameraden beeindrucken
wenn die eher aggressiv gestimmt waren
richteten sich die kerle ganz nach ihnen
anders herum passiert das kaum da sich
die mädchen eher an ältere halten
neben dem intimbereich entwickelt sich
vor allem das gehirn der pubertät
beispielsweise verändert sich die
blutzirkulation deutlich im kindesalter
fließen rund 100 milliliter blut durch
100 gramm gehirnmasse in der minute
umso älter man wird umso weniger blut
fließt durch das gehirn bis man das
erwachsenenalter erreicht hat verliert
man etwa 50 prozent der blutmenge die
noch im kindesalter durch das gehirn
geflossen ist zurück zur pubertät bis
zum zwölften lebensjahr sinkt die
blutzirkulation im gehirn bei beiden
geschlechtern gleich ab dem 16
lebensjahr sinkt die im gehirn von
männern deutlich stärker bei mädchen
steigt sie dagegen wieder leicht an
speziell im orbit frontalen kortex
dieser ist mitverantwortlich für das
sozialverhalten und die emotionen anhand
dieser entwicklung erhofft man sich
schon bald erklären zu können ob diese
blutzirkulation für das häufige
auftreten zb von depressionen bei frauen
verantwortlich ist
ja im gehirn verändert sich so einiges
während der pubertät dass ich dann auch
psychische erkrankungen entwickeln
können ist wohl nicht allzu
verwunderlich aber das ist schon
erschreckend 20 prozent der
pubertierenden haben wohl so in etwa
schwierigkeiten mit ihrer psyche während
der pubertät externer unterstützung von
profis wie psychologen oder psychiatern
ist bei zehn prozent der jugendlichen
wirklich erforderlich
besonders gefährlich ist die einstellung
der betroffenen jugendlichen man will
sich ja schließlich in der pubertät nie
schwach zeigen oder sagen dass man
schwierigkeiten hat so passiert es ganz
schnell dass sie erkranken sich immer
tiefer in die krankheit ein graben eine
behandlung auf einer gesprächsbasis ist
dann kaum mehr möglich bzw überhaupt
erfolgsversprechend medikation und ein
langer weg zurück ins leben steht dann
oft mit auf dem plan
deswegen wenn ihr merkt irgendwas stimmt
nicht habt mut und meldet euch macht
euer umfeld darauf aufmerksam redet mit
euren vertrauten personen
da wir gerade viel über psyche
gesprochen haben mutismus mutismus ist
eine krankheit die menschen schweigen
lässt
mehr zu dieser fast unbekannten
erkrankung erfahrt ihr hier im video
oben zu rap und zum blog wie immer da
unten alle links natürlich auch in der
video beschreibung und habt ihr eigene
erfahrungen zu den genannten fakten hier
im video gemacht
lasst es uns in den kommentaren wissen
ich bin sehr interessiert bis dann
bleibt dran